hey how'd you know I was here um well I  had a little help  sold me out  their true friend oh you're not angry  with him  in fact you respect him because he  prevented you from making a mistake boy  I'd love to get in on that hug no cuz  it's over you'd be stupid to hug now  they didn't till my bike nah talked  about it oh but they towed my car  instead yeah the guy came all the way  down and he had to leave with something  gotta eat man look his you have to drive  me on my bike he ya drive you on that  I got a slight buzz off in that 11 beer  I shouldn't drive I'm not street-legal  grifter you know Bret what's gonna be  Megas waiting boy she's a lot of bike no  I didn't look at us man get on the road  I feel feel free it's so silly hey man I  love this before but I kind of love it  that gives me a sense relief I didn't  Oh